welcome back I'm Steve Brunton and this
is the third video in a sequence on
exponential growth in the last video I
gave you examples of many systems that
grow exponentially and kind of how the
bigger your system grows the faster it
grows and in this video I'm gonna talk
about why it's called exponential growth
we're going to kind of derive Euler's
number II that kind of describes how
this exponential growth problem happens
we're going to use this to understand
differential equations and how
differential equations give rise to this
exponential growth phenomena so this is
really really cool and first of all I
think oiler is just one of the coolest
mathematicians who ever lived he
revolutionised so many fields of math
and physics and Euler's number II and
the exponential is one of the greatest
achievements in mathematics it is the
backbone the cornerstone of differential
equations which we use for modeling and
for control theory really really
powerful stuff here okay and it all
comes about because of exponential
growth alright so we talked about one
example of exponential growth was how
your money grows when you invest it in
the bank and when you reinvest your
returns you get this exponential kind of
compound growth of your money over time
and so we're gonna go back to that
example here so we're going to say that
X K is how much money I have this year
XK plus 1 is how much money I have next
year and we're going to assume that I
have an interest rate of 5% so I take my
money this year times 1.05 that tells me
how much money I have next year if I add
$100 I'll have 105 the next year that's
my 5% interest rate okay and what we're
going to start thinking about is instead
of that interest being applied once a
year what if I find a really great bank
that's willing to
pound that interest twice a year instead
of once a year so instead of just giving
me another five dollars at the end of
the year my bank gives me a 2.5 percent
interest rate after six months and it
gives me another 2.5 percent after the
next six months after twelve months so
that's compounded twice a year and what
you would do is you would take your
interest rate divided by two and then
you would take that and multiply it
twice because you're applying it every
six months twice a year and you'll
notice that the return is slightly
higher now our effective rate of return
is 5.06 percent so if I put in $100 I
get one hundred and five dollars and six
cents now that six cents doesn't seem
like a lot but it is more and so we want
to do it okay we want our interest
compounded twice a year not once a year
but this begs the question what if I
compound my interest monthly so twelve
times a year so now we take our interest
rate and we divide it by twelve and
that's how much we get every month and
we get it every month so twelve months
so we multiply it twelve times and that
means that the first month when I get a
little bit of interest I reinvest that
interest and the second month I get a
little bit more interest because I get
interest on my interest that's why we're
taking this to the 12th power and when
we accomplice lightly better effective
rate we get one hundred and five dollars
and twelve cents after a year you could
keep going what if I compound every
single day so I take my rate divided by
365 I take that to the 360 fifth power
and you're gonna see that your rate goes
up still now it's one hundred and five
dollars and 13 cents okay and you could
ask yourself what if I compound more and
more what if I compound every second of
every day what if I compound every
millisecond of every day and so you
could take this to its logical
conclusion you could take the limit as
you break up time break up your year
into infinitely many infinitesimal times
and you compound continuously on every
single one of those times so
mathematically we write that as 1 plus
our interest rate divided by N to the
nth power and we take the limit as n
goes to infinity we're breaking time up
into these infinitesimal moments and
we're
pounding continuously and when we do
that we see that this eventually
converges to something you know very
similar to compound it daily which is a
rate of one hunt one of five point one
three percent and so this number we
define this number to be e to the power
point O five e to my interest rate R
gives me one point O five one three and
so this first of all it says the
compounded continuously actually does
give you a better return than compounded
once a year
now I'm gonna swap out this point O five
does five percent for a generic rate R
and we can go through the exact same
math and we can see what happens if we
compound twice a year monthly daily or
continuously and again what we're going
to do is we're going to define this
compounded continuously rate as e to the
power R where there's just some number E
and we're gonna define this as e to the
power R now if you took a rate of R
equals one then e to the power one is
just e and so this is how we're gonna
define e the base of the natural
logarithm as it's sometimes called it's
also Oilers number it's the limit as n
goes to infinity of 1 plus 1 over N to
the power n okay and this is essentially
the the nugget the kernel of this
exponential growth if you had continuous
compounding interest okay really really
important number that explains how you
get more when you compound continuously
now I love this picture of Euler just as
an aside you'll notice that most
pictures of Euler are taken from one
side that's because he had a good eye
there was a challenge at the time when
when he was alive the King made an
astronomical challenge to predict some
astronomical event and all of the great
mathematicians and scientists of the era
tried to solve this problem and predict
this event and Euler being the intense
gentleman that he was poured over his
scientific data so every night he would
have one eye
as telescope observing observing the sky
and the other I would be writing these
figures down and running calculations
and night after night he split his
attention between the Stars and between
his figures and although he solved this
problem and did become famous he went
blind in one eye and ruined his his
sight in one of his eyes and I think
that just goes to show you kind of this
incredible focus and dedication and
intensity that many mathematicians have
had over time anyway Oilers number very
important more important than just
compound interest I'm gonna plot here
now one plus R this is how much you
would get back if you compounded once a
year and then e to the R if you
compounded continuously is always more e
to the R is always bigger than 1 plus R
and for small R it's not much better
remember we only got like 13 more sense
when R was 0.05 but when R is bigger
when R is 1 or 2 or 3 then this
compounded continuously gets better and
better and better faster okay so that's
really cool now you can also take this
discrete-time representation where my
money one year grows the next year and
the next year and the next year and you
can write this in continuous time as a
differential equation if you're getting
compounded continuously if your interest
is compounded continuously you can write
down this differential equation and so
what this says is that the rate of
change of my money every moment in time
is equal to R times X it's equal to my
rate times how much money I have in the
bank account now so the rate of change
of how much money I have is directly
proportional to how much money I have
and this totally makes sense this is
basically a statement of the rich get
richer faster the more money you have
the more money you make faster ok and
this simple linear differential equation
is the basis of kind of all of dynamical
systems and differential equations and
the solution is given by this nice
expression X at some future time T any
time five years and three days later
whatever
is e to the R times T R is my rate T is
time eetu the R T times how much money I
started with so the amount of money I
have at some future time is the amount I
had to start with times e to the RT and
this is what e to the RT looks like you
get this kind of nice exponential growth
and it just gets faster and faster and
faster as time goes on so I think this
is really cool
first of all just I love differential
equations and E is pivotal in how we
solve differential equations it's how we
understand compounded continuously
interest and it's how we understand lots
and lots of exponential growth processes
okay so in the next lecture I'm gonna
tell you how all good things must end
and how even exponential growth systems
eventually curtail and saturate and how
there's other effects in these
differential equations higher order
effects that eventually caused our
exponential growth to end because you
can't grow exponentially forever
eventually your population you know
reaches a limit or you have all the
money that there is or whatever you
can't exponentially grow to infinity in
real systems so that's we're going to
talk about next time stay tuned thanks